if I look back through through my career
particularly in the US the best
candidates that I've placed over the
years have then gone on to place their
friends their ex- colleagues the best
people that they've worked with they're
the same people who have then opened
doors for me and the clients that I now
support are their previous clients
welcome back to another episode of the
recruitment mentors podcast I'm your
host hea mazus and on this week's
episode I was joined by Elliot Jones
from Venturi you've uh always been in
recruitment and worked for one company
Venturi which you're still with now
you're now actually over in the States
but for the first uh chunk of your
career uh you worked in the UK Market it
was always Dev Tech Elliott's always
been in contract Recruitment and for the
last four years he's solely focused on
the US market he moved over to
specifically New York just over two
years ago and he's been on some Journey
he was the first in the company to break
a number of Milestones where he got got
his contract book up to 35k weekly GP
but then it took a massive hit his book
went all the way down at the lowest to
3K weekly GP in January
2023 and he's now got this back up to
Circa 25k weekly GP so in this
conversation we cover how he got to his
Peak how he opened up doors how he has
become exceptional at standing feature
Advantage benefit when selling
contractors just so much value in this
conversation what information are you
then looking to gather that would make
your Market map cuz I think that would
be helpful for people cuz like what does
that look like yeah for me it's about
let's get into this week's
episode Elliot welcome to the
podcast welcome well thank you thanks
for having me yeah looking look looking
forward to this
obviously uh I was sort of I I said to
you
that have had a lot of perm Recruiters
on on this podcast and uh I'm really
excited to dive into the Journey of some
uh successful contract recruiters that
there's a real difference I'm sure
there's a lot of crossover but there's
also a lot of nuances that comes with
making it in contract recruitment so I'm
looking forward to uh really digging
into this journey that you've been on um
so just to give everyone some immediate
context I'm I'm going to give everyone
the Highlight Reel okay so if I if I get
anything wrong please correct me all
right so when we prepared for this these
are the things that you shared with me
so you've uh always been in Recruitment
and worked for one company Venturi which
you're still with now you're now
actually over in the States but for the
first uh chunk of your career uh you
worked in the UK Market it was always
Dev Tech um and the first couple of
years correct me if I'm wrong here
2016 uh I think we did weekly GP didn't
we so I think 2016 your weekly GP was
around 2 and a half 3K 2017 you got up
to 6 and 1 half 7 2018 um your third
year was around 6 and a half 7 and a
half again then you actually went a bit
more hands off and started to manage the
team um and then Feb 2020 is the next
sort of uh key bits that we' got cuz you
then started to do the US market is that
right yeah so you the plan was to do it
for under a year for sure it might have
been six months and then go to the us
but as you all know Co happened so you
was absolutely grafting your socks off
in the UK do the US hours but now how
long have you been in the US actually on
the ground uh on the ground two years
two years yeah so you've been in New
York in the US for two years so from the
US side of things let me just scroll
down here because you give me you looked
in your back end so Feb 2022 started the
US so December 20 20 you hit 10K weekly
GP by March 2020 you hit 20K weekly GP
by May 2020 you hit 25k weekly GP um and
then you held um it around there uh
until 2021 may you hit 30k weekly GP and
then at the end of May you Pete you
surpassed 35k weekly GP and then from
October
2022 we hit doomsday mate it started to
it started to dramatically drop off and
then at the lowest in March I'm assuming
was this March 2023 it was no no that
that was 2022 okay sorry yeah so at the
lowest it then got down to 3K weekly GP
2020 uh around 202 sorry yeah sorry 2023
that is yeah yeah yeah cool yeah I
thought so so from October you said from
October 2022 it really began to
dramatically drop off at the lowest
around March time this year was a 3K
and then now um you've got that back up
to 20 to 25k weekly
GP yeah yeah it's been a roller coaster
all right cool so that that's the
Highlight re so let let's start with the
the million the million dollar question
in your world I'd love to get your
thoughts perspective on what does
Elliott believe are the common
characteristics and traits of a
successful top performing contract
recruiter in today's
market uh there's so many to cover um
and you hear kind of the the same
answers get get thrown around work ethic
resilience intelligence helps
obviously not so much being books smart
but your emotional intelligence your EQ
um but also problem solving abilities a
lot a lot of recruitment is is kind of
solution selling and and being able to
uncover that solution and and and find
uh uncover that problem sorry and find
the the most kind of suitable solution
um same as like be a sponge take on kind
of every bit of advice learn from what
the good people do well what the bad
people don't do so well um but if I had
to kind of narrow it down I think the
the big one for me and and ventory as a
whole is is relationship building um
it's it's so important to be able to
kind of build those strong relationships
with both your candidates and your
clients
um but also I find being able to kind of
build those relationships but then
leverage those to open doors for you if
I look back through through my career
particularly in the US the best
candidates that I've placed over the
years have then gone on to place their
friends their ex- colleagues the best
people that they've worked with they're
the same people who have then open doors
for me and the clients that I now
support are their previous clients the
biggest names that I've kind of broken
in with over time and typically off the
back of top relationships I've built
with candidates who have then moved on
but helped me open doors by giving me
good Intel on the businesses often
directly making introductions because
they've received a good service so yeah
got to be able to build those
relationships but also be able to
leverage them um to to benefit um see
love it so relationship building is is
at the core and then being able to like
you said actually like if you do have a
relationship then these people are going
to be willing to help you um and and
doing that effectively
so so I was just going to say I think
over time my kind of attitude to this
stuff's slight slightly changed it's
funny I saw a post on LinkedIn the other
week um and it was from someone out out
of the industry um but they posted like
a a basically a study that had been
conducted um by JP Morgan or Goldman on
like the top performing investment
bankers and the highlights it was like
out of all the top form in investment
Investment Bank is the kind of only one
consistent trait that all of them had
was like this inflated kind of
self-belief and self-confidence and I
read it I was thinking that rings so
true for our industry um like for me
that's where my kind of resilience comes
from because I'm always thinking I've
always had this belief that I'm going to
do well in the end so the only way I can
kind of fail is if I quit um and
obviously that's got be married with
humility and being humble but I think an
underlying like self-confidence that
you're going to succeed in whatever
industry you're working will certainly F
Well in in this in this space absolutely
so the sort of what I want us to like
really dig into is this Us Journey that
you've been on because I feel like this
will be most front of mind and I just
think it's just like the right period to
really focus on so I guess what where I
want us to to
start is at that beginning period
because I've got here on my notes when
we prepared for this um again feel free
to correct me but I think you said in
the first six months you found it
extremely difficult and didn't do one
deal right yeah I think I did one in my
first six months so it was yeah so you
did one contract deal in your first
first six months of like building the US
market from scratch cuz you was the
first person to do right for Ventura you
was doing it from scratch is that right
or is that wrong not fully from scratch
no we had a we had a team on the ground
doing it already so we had a small
database I think there was three or four
of them on contract when I started no
there yeah three the two two kind of
directors who said it up they'd hired a
few people who didn't necessarily work
out and then one one lad who who was was
doing doing starting to to have some
success and doing well but it was all
very green it had been a kind of no more
than a couple of years of kind of
setting up the US and getting things off
the ground okay so you but you was doing
it from the UK and then the first six
months like you said you did you did one
deal so would you mind let like let's
just start in that period like what was
what was the game plan so did you have a
niche that you was focusing on or did
you figure that out as you as you went
what were some of like the initial goals
that you wanted to to try and achieve in
that initial period like what was the
initial plan um in those uh early days
what was the strategy
so for me it was a relatively relatively
straightforward transition because I was
always doing Dev in the UK moved over to
do Dev I was doing javascripts in the UK
the team I oversaw in in the UK on the
London Market with JavaScript recruiters
so it was kind of plug and play from a
technical side um but in terms of the
plan like it's relatively
straightforward it was speak to as many
candidates possible in my core patch
establish what good looks like because
once you have kind of a
um point of reference on what a top
candidate looks like what kind of work
they've done but also what like high bar
sites of they work for you know where to
spend your time and then spend as much
time as possible particularly in the
initial period Speaking to as many of
those candidates as possible um on the
premise that good candidates will give
you good leads and good
information okay so speak to as many
candidates as possible so just help me
understand then why have as a let's just
take the example as a JavaScript
developer why would I give you my time
uh when you know like what what would
you have to offer me what would be the
value exchange if you know you can't
speak to me or highlight any potential
projects that they might be interested
in like you know understand like why
you'd want to do that but why would they
why would they give you the time what
was the the compelling reason that you
gave to people yeah well fortunately I
came in and there were people on the
market already so we did have jobs to
work I could bring them some value MH be
that not to the level that I would like
or or we're at now as a business so it
was always coming with with something um
but so often in recruitment it's not
plug and play in a lot of the candidates
that I'm speaking with might not be
perfect for the roles that I'm working
particularly if you're targeting the top
candidates and then it can be a slightly
kind of disappointing conversation on
their side if you're coming with a role
but you can't get to the numbers that
they're expecting or from a seniority
perspective it's not at the level that
that they would want um but then it's
about displaying your understanding of
the market and trying to kind
of extract information from them but
bring value with what you know about
what's going on in the market who is
hiring be that my clients or or others
um I'm always of the attitude that every
conversation is look I might not place
you now now but I want to I want to know
what makes you tick and what's important
to you so that when the the right
opportunity does arise your first first
kind of portal call um and I'm confident
over time I will place you at some point
so I want to be on your radar and I'll
be in touch set the precedent there that
I'll be in touch every kind of three to
six weeks to see how things are going
the contract Market evolves so quickly
and people start contracts work for six
months do a great job and move on and be
available again so building those
relationships and kind of then seeing
the value in connecting with you
consistently really important so let me
let me ask you this then so I I'd
probably say that you know if if I'm
listening to this and I'm uh you know
even a perm recruiter but a contract
recruiter I'm going to hear very quickly
speech your candidates get leads get
information build relationships like the
these are probably things that everyone
has like heard time and time again
particularly from their managers who
have been doing it for a long time and
you know you've already stressed the
importance of that in this short time so
what what I'd love to just like hear
your take on is I wanted to answer this
question from like two perspectives one
like what did Elliot's calls with
candidates sound like when you wasn't
doing a very good job of what sounds
like fundamental to being a contract
recruiter in terms of building
relationships getting information like
yeah like get maximizing the the
candidate relationship so then you can
get leaves and do what you need to do so
what did your call sound like where
maybe you wasn't doing that good of a
job of that you was doing it but maybe
not as good as you are doing it now like
what would be some of the differences
because I'm sure you help people with
this you tell them do this do that but
then they're just not very good at it
like what what might the cool how
different will the cool sound and what
are you doing that's
different so yeah I think from a lead G
perspective I love the whole give to get
kind of um method and thought process
but we' you've got to kind of uh and
what's changed for me quite dramatically
is the concept of calling a candidate
talking through their experience and
asking them where they're interviewing
isn't going to get you where you need to
be so it's being super granular on
everything contract recruitment is is
kind of so 360 in the sense that
everything comes back around the more
kind of granular you can be and the more
detail you can go in about every single
one of their projects where they worked
as a contractor and get them to spell
out for you what did you do what were
the projects that you delivered what was
your focus get them to explain the
feature Advantage benefit of what
they've delivered so that not only can I
then take that candidate and sell them
into other clients with true credibility
because I understand what makes them
valuable um but I've also then got where
that candidate provided value to their
previous employer and can find other
people with similar skill sets that can
kind of a align with that
um kind of fast forward to to now and
where we're at my network is so big and
the team that we work with have their
own network that there is so often
correlations with who I know who I've
placed who I've worked with from the
sites that they've worked at so in terms
of give to get if I'm going into a call
with hean from Hector I've got a market
map up in front of me of every manager
or candidate I've spoken to who's worked
at Hector before and I'm going to name
drop I've placed X Out of Hector I've
worked with this candidate um did you
know any of these guys and as soon as
you get a yes your credibility goes
through the roof and their walls come
down and they're so open to giving you
information because you're already in
like as far as they're concerned you
know these people so they're not
divulging any kind of uh Trade Secrets
by telling you who their manager was or
who the best people that they worked
with on um X Project were because you're
already given them oh I've worked with
this person I placed this person here
and that really kind of breaks down
barriers and it takes time to get there
but we're all so commonly working with
teams who have done this before so we've
got to lean into those networks and when
we bring new people on I'll sit with
them and talk to them like who who have
you got calls with great this guy's
worked to exite I placed this candidate
who used to work there ask him if he
knows him and the barriers come down so
quickly and it makes it so much easier
to extract information because it's a
two-way conversation so it sounds like
okay so it sounds like maybe ear on in
your career it would have sounded like
Elliot was just
um trying to get information in a fairly
straightforward way of like hey Elliot
can see you've done this this and this
just sort of checking that this is all
correct um also like where else are you
interviewing like it was very much like
get and you wasn't giving anything um
and then what you're saying is um as
youve obviously built out your career
you've really um had to learn how to
leverage the relationships and the
people that you've worked with in the
past that can give you um credibility
but also what you've had to get better
at is rather than it just being that
transactional in the sense of like okay
so you've done this you've done that um
where else are you interviewing you're
also then really trying to
showcase your credibility by uh like you
said the Fab feature Advantage benefit
really trying to understand what they've
done um in the projects that they've
worked in and these types of things yeah
and then your questioning goes a level
deeper early on in everybody's career
they'll typically ask a question because
it's a question that they've been told
to ask or that they've learned is a good
question to ask they'll get an answer
they might even make note of the answer
to to refer back to it but then they'll
move on whereas the the why is always
three four five questions deep so when
you get on to kind of specific project
details don't stop at the first answer
that you get because typically the first
answer that you get is surface level and
that's not the valuable information that
that you're looking for from candidates
it's what what was the the true why get
as deep as you can to understand what
makes these candidates tick but also
where do they add value because that
makes selling them so much easier but
also makes you uncover the problems that
they were solving for the clients that
they're supporting and that then makes
your solution selling so much easier
from a lead gen perspective so let's
let's just round this out then and let
me ask you this so like if I'm listening
to this right now and I feel like I can
improve my contractor conversations just
in terms of maybe like either improve
them by um I want to improve them by
trying to Showcase my credibility more
or I want improve them by like you said
like just trying to get a bit more
deeper not being in the surface level
and ultimately like build those
relationships at um a better level
what's like one thing that I could
incorporate in my next contractor call
that you think would help me achieve
some of those things just one thing
research look at who you've got
connections in common with ask them
about them look at where they've worked
reference people that have worked there
going seeming like a subject ma expert
cuz they is Crossover with things
they've done people they've worked with
and people that you've worked with or
placed or worked jobs for love that
super smart and then Ju Just quickly on
that can do because I'm I'm thinking if
I'm listening to this like well I
haven't got anyone to reference right
can I have you found it can you also
reference what your like what your
colleagues have done if you get what I
mean so like absolutely yeah cuz I think
some sometimes that's a bit of a cop out
isn't it well Elliot I haven't I haven't
got a track record yet but you know can
I do the research and find out who my
colleagues I'm sure everyone listening
to this have has some senior people
around them can I leverage who my
company or my team have worked with to
gain that credibility in what you just
said absolutely and just use the word we
because yeah would be nice it's like oh
we've done loads of work with X I
actually might not have done any of that
but I know what my colleagues done and
it still attributes the same value um
and I would highly encourage all of them
to leverage my network if you're on a
call with someone and you know they've
worked at ex company and I've placed
loads of people out of there ask me and
I'll give you a name the names of the
best people so you can reference that
and it'll instantly build your
credibility yeah not awesome so I I was
curious when you're going for that
period of time and you've done one deal
and obviously you've been used to doing
way more than one deal
previously like and and I'm sure again
like you've had to go through this when
you're um book took a real hit what what
are like some of like the important
metrics that you look at that just give
you confidence that things are going to
turn and things are going to start going
your way and things are going to start
picking up do you know what I mean what
are some of the the sort of Le um
leading indicators that make you feel
like you know what no if I keep doing
this I'm confident it's going to pay off
and hopefully in another couple of
months time I'm going to be doing way
more deals and this might open up what
are some of like the core things that
you look at when you're not getting like
theend outcome of contractor deals in
but you might be having I don't know
like multiple conversations with hiring
managers that say in 6 month time we are
going to be kicking off a project I
don't know what the leading indicators
are but what are some of the things that
you keep a close on a close eye on that
help you feel confident if you keep
doing what you're doing it's going to
pay off um
yeah like I'm a big believer like
measure what matters it's really easy in
recruitment to go really granular and
look at every single kpi to assess what
the outcome's going to be but I try and
keep it really simple how many
candidates am I speaking to and of those
candidates what hot leads am i g what
hot site information I I getting and
then how many clients am I speaking to
and how are those calls progressing how
many of those calls typically every
client call I have there'll be some
follow-up bu in off the back of that
whether it's a month down the line two
months down the line a year down the
line as long as you can set expectations
on if not now when can I be of value to
you um and if that's never no problem
I'll check with you again in six months
and see how things have progressed uh as
long as there are a contract higher in
your space that makes sense to keep that
conversation in your in your world so
you said uh you you mentioned something
there watch I just want to make sure
people understand because I haven't
heard that terminology before so you
said number of candid conversations yeah
um number of hot
leads and then you said number of what
did you say site something oh just
client conversation like you said hot
leads and and site um projects or
something or like something like that I
I might be wrong I feel like you said
hot Le and you said and you said their
number of sites just just contract sites
yeah what does that mean contract
sites the the core difference between
contracts and per and why I personally
find business development on the
contract side so much more challenging
is because every company who hire
software engineers in the world
typically will have at least one full
full time software engineer and we'll
hire them but such a finite number of
companies hire contractors never mind
contractors at volume so by tracking
sites who hire contractors right there
we go s that's what you said sites that
hire contractors got you over time
you're going to build a list of credible
companies who you know take contractors
and by staying in touch delivering good
content sure okay that makes sense so
hot leads in terms of like actual jobs
that you could potentially Place
contractors into to but the other thing
is how many times a week am I learning
and understanding what companies hire
contractors right okay that makes sense
got you all right that's fine I just
wanted to make sure that we Define that
because maybe not everyone will use that
terminology I'm not sure so and then you
said number of client conversations and
how they're progressing is is like the
other just key things that you keep
measuring um and then Okay cool so why
don't why don't let let me ask you this
then um if it's difficult to know you
might have a bit of an idea just might
be helpful for people what does good
look like on on those sorts of key
things if we're keeping it simple like
what are like the the core metrics that
you found always to be like if I'm
having these sorts of number of
conversations it should result in good
outcomes it's hard because your kpis
evolve over time and the more Junior you
are the more you need to do to execute
on the same volume but I try to keep
myself to a minimum of five candidates a
day and three clients um if you're
speaking to to five candidates every day
should if you're spending your time
outreaching to the right people and
connecting with the right people good
candidates will bring good leads
likewise if you're reaching out to
contract sites who you know higher
contractors speak to three a day and you
will grow your client Network um and you
will begin to do business with them
where people so often go wrong is those
five candidates if they're all of had
response they don't have or they aren't
top candidates in your Market they're
going to give you crappy information
likewise if those sites are just anyone
who hires in my world JavaScript
Engineers 80% of them are likely to not
hire contractors so your time is wasted
if we're not targeting the 20 to 30% who
do hire contractors and speaking to the
top candidates that you've identified as
these are good guys good candidates good
clients will give you good information
um so just about speaking to the right
people but a good volume of them you
always need the volume to get there nice
five and three yeah that's fairly
straightforward that's I think people
always interested in like what the other
people work to and stuff so that's super
helpful I started at 10 10 and 10 when I
when I was like when I well 10 years
start
recruitment that was 10 candidates 10
clients and 10 specs and okay in terms
of kind of the quality that
diminishes with the volume so it's it's
all a balancing act but yeah well that's
good to know though right as as you were
coming up that it was pretty much double
um so Tau me like when I say to you what
what started to shift what what was like
the lead Domino or when did you start to
notice things were shifting Because by
the end of that 2020 year first six
months so you started in Fair first six
months did one deal but then by the end
of 2020 you got up to 10K weekly GP
so looking back at that what what
changed or like what were some of the
things that started to happen that then
Ena you to start building
momentum I think it was a build process
um we had a market established but I
didn't really have clients that I could
come in and straight away have access to
working jobs I had to kind of eat what I
killed um and that takes time building a
market takes time I think it probably
took me
um a bit of time to establish who the
best hirers were in my market um which
is something now that is a little more
prescribed when people come in because
we can guide them on look this is where
if you spend your
time on candidate gen around these sites
you're going to quickly uncover High
Caliber candidates who will give you
high caliber information and then your
Market Maps building the hierarchies of
these companies and understanding who
the decision makers are what makes them
what their interests are and how to
reach out to them again took time um had
a few things that didn't land my way um
I think in that time had two or three
offers that just didn't didn't land and
uh from perhaps a number of reasons but
um yeah I think the things started to
turn for me as I started to really
understand the market
uh at that point i' then built kind of
credible Market Maps on the companies
who I was targeting and it was a lot
easier for them to start to topple um
also took a little more pride in my
content and marketing and that was a big
kind of turning point for me when I
began obsessing over Fab in every kind
of element of my career be that specs
tailored kind of specs to hot leads
eshots selling candidates on the phone
the more I spoke in terms of feature
Advantage benefit and selling Against
Time quality and cost the more results
started to to come in um and I think
that was a particularly in a hot
Market was a was a a major turning
point talk to me about what does because
you mentioned it quite a lot already
when you're aiming to Market map like
what what are like the the core pillars
of of the market map that you're looking
to build like so if you're you know if
you recognize that there's there's a
site that you know hires good quality
good caliber contractors cuz you managed
to build a relationship with one you
know they're very much up there from
your view in terms of like a great
contractor um you know that you know
they've got eight other contractors
there at the moment um but you haven't
been able to sort of open up the door
there but you found out that information
what what then what then are you looking
to what information are you then looking
to gather that would make your Market
map cuz I think that' be helpful for
people cuz like what does that look like
yeah for me it's about building a
hierarchy understanding
who the top decision makers are and who
sits underneath them who can influence
the process um it's so easy to get a hot
lead and if you do get the manager name
obsess that that guy or or girl or
individual is the only person who's
going to be able to get you in the door
um partic
the the way I approach it my market Maps
particularly those On Target sites these
are bigger companies these are kind of
Enterprise brand names and there's so
many people who can influence the
process and open the door for you that
you've got to spend the time speaking to
as many different candidates that work
there as possible to understand all the
different teams the different setups but
not only that how did they get the job
do they even work with recruiters does
everybody come through a consultancy or
um a pass through vendor and if that
that is the case great that gives me a
complete New Market map to start on said
consultancy or a new approach to a
specific pass through vendor this is who
I need to speak to and kind of build a
relationship with to place with ex
client um and I think that's slightly
different to the UK and wasn't something
that I was massively privy to um it was
a little more you get in direct and and
that's that um whereas yeah that's been
a huge part of kind of our success and
business model is understanding who who
the who the hiring managers are that I
need to Target and open a door with and
then how do they actually hire see if
it's feasible for us to work together or
how it's feasible for us to work
together and are you putting this all in
what old school spreadsheet or no I'm a
little obsessive with it so my market
maps are like slap pages and pages long
uh we use bullhorn as as our kind of
database um and we have kind of a market
mapping system where I'll Target clients
based on their location industry and the
tax tax that they typically hire for
being a JavaScript specialist they're
all pretty replicable but in each of
mine I'll take pride over the way it
looks because I'll use them all day
every day every candid all in it's all
in bullhorn sorry all all in bullhorn
okay cool every candidate that I speak
to from a certain site will go into my
market map their manager name their team
name their project information the skill
set that they used what problem they
solved if you get on a good rapport with
a candidate what their manager likes
what their sports teams are what their
interests out of work are um because
that stuff all goes into getting
referenced when I'm reaching out and
being specific um so yeah I'll track all
of that and then for every site as as I
said there's multiple different teams
multiple different hire managers who can
influence the process if you've just got
one you're probably never going to break
that door down because you need more
data points to um to to open those doors
so take your time if you have a specific
Target client who you know higher at
volume and you know a uh a good hirer in
your market and pay the rates that
you're looking for obsess over that
client go and learn everything about
them drop down every candidate who's
worked there and
it gets easier the longer you do it
every candidate I speak to from exite I
reference the 10 other candidates who
I've spoke to and one of them they'll
know or the managers that they've spoke
to and the more you speak to the more
you get the same team names coming up
it's like oh you working the marketing
applications team I'm guessing you
worked under Jeff he's like oh yeah well
Jeff was my manager's manager I said who
was your direct manager and then you've
got more kind of information more points
of contact to reach out to so it sounds
like for everyone listening take your
admin
seriously yeah and really really commit
to it really commit to it I thought I
was crap admin and then I showed people
on my marketing office and like wow this
is really in depth because I kind of
obsessed about them and this was just
data Gathering rather than for me that
wasn't admin admin is adding my notes on
b or or or loging my interviews it's
like this is just recruitment this is
this is data your perception of it
changed what you were
doing and that's when it gets fun as
well like your conversations are so much
better quality and it's it's like
detective work it it's fun because
you're working out like who these
companies are
and how you can best approach to get in
with them um and the more granular you
go the better the results seem to be
this podcast is proudly partnered with
vin Cherry the all-in-one recruitment
agency software that over 20,000
recruiters trust daily we're also
partnered with the award-winning oneup
sales a sales and motivation platform
that enables you to maximize the
potential of your teams we love
partnering with both of these
organizations because they share our
mission in helping you get the most out
of your people and your business you can
get exclusive offers because you're
listen to this podcast and get up to 10%
of the usage price forever use a link in
the show notes to get your hands on that
let's get back to the episode so that
let's sort
of let let me ask you this I think this
would be helpful and I really because I
feel like we've really doubled down here
on like the candidate side but every
conversation I've had with a contract
recruiter it that seems so fundamental I
mean even definitely on like the the
perm side particularly when you're you
know opening up new markets building
things from scratch like information
gathering is so critical um and
people that take it seriously um like
you're just talking about uh then you
know have the upper hand when they're
speaking to people and also then you
know you're going to give yourself a
real you're just going to thank yourself
later on down the line right when you're
12 months 24 months in you're just going
to be I'm so glad I've documented all
this information and you know I hear
this time and time again even on the
perm side when recruits are building
markets from scratch like absolutely
fundamental to doing that successfully
and having success more quickly is
through the candidates and building
relationships but let's sort of move on
to you know business development and
client acquisition because I think you
know I've often heard that that's even
more difficult when it comes to uh being
in contract that that can uh sometimes
be even more challenging compared to the
perm side but would you mind just
sharing know at your at your Peak so
when we was at you know when we was
absolutely flying around that 35k weekly
GP mark would you mind sharing like what
your client spread look like cuz I think
that would be helpful like how many
clients did did you have around that
time um and how many contracts did you
have around that time I think that would
be helpful and then we can work back
from there in terms of what were some of
the most common ways and the most
effective ways that you brought on these
clients it might come back to candidates
again we'll find out but what what did
this client spread it like and what did
things look like when he was at your
Peak so ironically my spread was pretty
good at the start I probably across yeah
I was
running at high 35k off about 30 to 32
Runners um and the spread of kind of
clients across that Spectrum was pretty
broad um the market was hot so it was
relatively it was easier to open doors
withm um
and that meant that kind of I didn't
think it would ever drop off as kind of
quickly as it did but
um yeah it was um
um yeah around around 32 32 Runners a
peak um and I I think from a BD strategy
a lot of that came off the back of
obsessing over my content because your
smmes have fewer barriers to entry you
can when we Sayes here we're talking
about small medum Enterprise like
smaller companies right and what did
that look like in the US what what did
an look like like how big in in the US
typically H again that that be anywhere
from 100 employees to 2,000 employees
it's quite broad broad spectrum but in
terms of their Tech presence I'd kind of
classified them as anme um
and yeah they typically were slightly
easier to bring on as as clients um but
in a hot Market when everyone's hiring
and anybody opens a contracts is is is
receptive they're a lot easier to bring
on there's fewer barriers to doing that
and
um it meant that I was consistently
pulling business off relatively
straightforward Business Development
practices pull hot leads get manager
names Chase leads send out kind of mass
content selling your best candidates and
through a combination of of all of that
meant that on a on a monthly basis I was
bringing in a a lot of new business um
and placing it all and of course quite a
few of those were just ones and two
um and then had two or three clients who
were four five sixes
um which were the ones that kind of tled
when when went so so how sorry so
you said you had about 32 Runners did
you say yeah between 30 and and 32 while
was fluctuating around yeah and how many
uh if you if you're not entirely sure
that's fine but like roughly how many
that how many client how many sites them
were you working with probably 10 to 12
10 to 12 and then what you saying is
three or four of those which were smes
had like fours and fives yeah and then
um there some of the ones that then
stopped and and said they no longer
needed
contractors yeah yeah I um because I I
held around 25k for about a year and
that kind of fluctuated and some of the
bigger repeat businesses continue to
hire and at some point I might have had
8 to 12 with a couple of different
different sites and some of the one-off
businesses dropped off um but that was
okay because I was propping up with um
some of the slightly bigger ticket
business but we still in that
mediumsized kind of category um but
again that meant that when the market
did turn in certain businesses took a
hit it was a a much quicker and more
Stark drop off yeah so what Ju Just
describe to us like what what that
looked like then so you're saying so
looking at my notes here it was say so
yeah from October 2022 it began to
dramatically uh drop like what did what
did that what did that actually look
like was it did you get like multiple
phone calls in a week saying hey
Elliot like what did that what did that
did it like happen all literally in one
because I feel like when I has spoke to
contract recruit this can literally
happen overnight can't it so like what
did this actually sound like what did it
actually happen did you just get
multiple phone calls that week was it
quite a big
surprise so it was so of probably the
three or larger clients who I was
supporting at the time I got couple of
phone calls were letting go of X team of
contractors and I'd kind of landed and
expanded into different teams so I might
lose a team of three onone project but
I've still got a couple over there um
and then a couple of weeks later they
all got caught um and then another
business I was working with at the time
was like look we're out of business for
we're out of budget for for contract
hires every one of the contractors that
we've got coming we'll see out their
contracts but between now and March
they're all going to end so it was just
and that at that point it was a little
painful because I was like I know
these are all finishing yeah and it was
quite a high volume so I was battling to
place more than was finishing at that
point
um uh and it's funny I was looking into
before this like from a b d perspective
when was I kind of performing best and
I'd always say the run up to hit in your
Peak is where you're actually performing
cuz when they all start you're kind of
spinning your wheels you've got a lot of
things going on and this is why
organization and structure is so
important because it came to the point
where I was so busy I was doing six plus
deals every month for a few months on
the run that my BD took a hit because I
knew I've got to find these candidates
um I'm fully 360 model no one else is
doing this for me so um got to go and
find the the right people and at that
point BD definitely took a backseat um
so this time that like you weren't you
weren't having CL me you were having
like no client meetings or you weren't
pulling hot Le yeah just the volume
dramatically decreased um because I knew
all these jobs were coming in I had to
fill them and if I didn't my competition
would I'm quite a competitive person and
that that drives me if I know it's a
competitive job I'll deliver
and typically
will kind of thrive in that situation
but um yeah that meant that during that
period I was managing quite a big team
at the same at the same time and between
filling my own jobs and overseeing a
team of at one point like 11 um was kind
of eating away all the time that I had
so a lot of my BD took a back seat and
it was I get a hot lead I trace it but
previously where I'd have employed good
Cadence and been in touch every two to
three weeks following up that probably
fell to the Wayside client calls will
have dropped but on a big picture I
probably did six months of doing
multiple deals every month and it looked
green and Rosy but under the hood I knew
I'm not being as consistent as I need to
be from a BD perspective that's taking a
backseat to other priorities and that's
kind of put me in a fresh mindset this
time around um now I've rebuilt this on
what I would call more solid foundations
um and it it might mean that some months
I sacrifice a deal because actually I'm
not going to spend my time chasing this
that's a little bit off core although I
historically had a good chance of
filling it I'm going to focus on BD
because that's what's going to feed me
for the next few months and make sure
that new business continues to come in
at the same rate so if I do have finish
ises and um there is a kind of Exodus as
there was um I've got enough new so so I
want to I want to talk about this but
just before we go into because I think
what what I'd be stupid not to ask you
is then like you know with hind site and
it sounds like this is what you're
talking about now you know for people
listening what can they be doing to
protect their book right or protect
their book from you know getting to the
point where it got to but just before
before we get to that I I have to ask
cuz like you know this is I think even
more true when it comes to contract
recruitment I spoke to multiple people
where they've worked their absolute
socks off to get to you know that Peak
um and then you you know find yourself
walking in on Monday going how the
have I ended up here you know and and
you're back at this other point so just
talk to us like personally how did you
like digest that like how did you you
know like what did you do to help you
not think like this like oh my God
I just you know worked really hard I'm
now here like nearly back to square one
like how did you deal with that
personally yeah I mean I'm only human so
I was in a bad way for a couple of
months but so what what so what did that
look like what did the bad way look like
was you always Moody was you like just
really unmotivated like what did that
actually look like um I I think it was
more at home okay yeah I like I live and
breathe what I do I love it but I'm also
quite a high energy person and I think I
probably in a probably in a two Monon
period leading up to the the the low
point was a lower energy
um as I said my risk was pretty well
spread because I had a quite a few
different clients so I wasn't expecting
it all to drop off as starkly as it did
um
but as I said at the start like when I
reference the kind of um the Investment
Bank in study like I've always had this
kind of crazy self belief but at that
point impostor syndrome 100% kicked in I
I know I always sat there thinking did I
just get
lucky and I landed on a few good
accounts and then did really well off it
and yes I executed but was
that predominantly looking a bit of
skill or and but
then as soon as I thought that I was
like actually that's I know I
did this and that kind of fu me cuz I I
knew I was like other people might think
that if I'm if if part of impostor
syndrome is kind of getting to me here
and I'm thinking was that a better look
someone else is thinking that and that's
the person I need to go and kind of
prove wrong doing something once could
be a bit of luck but if I do this again
there's no doubt and if I can do this
twice I know I'm set because if anything
happens I can go and do it again I can
build a plan I can rebuild each time on
more St able foundations so I think that
kind of really motivated me and it was a
case of sitting
down chatting with some of the
leadership just to kind of
get a solid plan in place um but also I
knew that I couldn't let the negativity
in so I was like no I'm going to do this
and I'm going to hold myself accountable
so I remember saying
to people would always check in like how
are you doing obviously you've taken a
big hit you must be devastated and I
same response to everyone was give me
time I'll exceed what I did last time so
I was like if I tell other people that
it holds me accountable and I didn't
want to seem arrogant or cocky but I was
like that's just what you like get
devastated yeah I'm devastated but I'm
gonna do it and I fully believed I would
there was times where I was like me
what what's going on here how is how has
it gone from the craziest paycheck
checks that I could imagine to to almost
back to my base um but deep down I
always knew I was like I'm going to do
it I just need to apply myself the only
way I can fail here is if I quit um and
initially it took a little bit longer to
rebuild than I'd liked the market was
definitely in a turbulent place and I
had to kind of
reash my approach to business
development because of so let's go into
that but just quickly if I'm listening
to this right now and I
I'm in the thick of like where you was
you know a lot of people um have had
difficult years this year particularly
in Tech I think there's definitely it
sounds like what you're
experiencing um obviously there's a
location um element here as well but
definitely a lot of people I spoke to
the last couple of months looking into
next year there is a lot more positive
sentiment for sure um but you know if
I'm listening to this right now and I am
at the depths I am you know where I'm
questioning like yeah was I just
lucky uh was it actually me that was
able to get to that High Point what what
would your advice be to them like what
is it that you'd actually say to them
what would be the the one bit of advice
you'd give them if if I'm in that low
moment right now yeah um it's hard
because the advice I'd give someone else
isn't theice I'd give myself I would ask
myself personally do you want
it if you want it and you want to prove
it go and do it but if you say I
wouldn't necessarily say it in so many
words to to someone else but I do think
there's got to be a self a point of
self-reflection say do you want it do
you believe you can go and do it cool go
and prove people wrong um recruitment's
a hard a hard game but it's simple tasks
and it's a accumulation of doing
relatively simple tasks consistently
over time if anything you've done once
in recruitment you can replicate so
you've just got to believe that and
don't let let the voices in that are
saying uh um like I say you can't do it
or um or that be that be the advice you
give yourself so why would it be
different then if it was to what what
would be what would the different advice
be to somebody else I probably say sit
down build a plan know what you got at
execute right yeah um how did you do it
last time what's changed and go and do
it again um because I'll probably always
be harder on myself than I will on other
people um of course because uh that
that's kind of how I how I am and yeah
the same that's why I was probably so
low because I was beating myself up have
let this happen um but the yeah comeback
is always bigger than the setback so
what what do you've said it a few times
so what does building now on more solid
foundations like what what does that
actually mean what what what makes your
contract book now built on more solid
foundations talk to us a bit about what
that actually means so I was talking to
the some of the guys on the board ventur
about this this week
like earlier in my career icept obsessed
about my content and getting good
content out to contract
hirers was what won me business and
having the best candidates and selling
them in the most credible way but in a
tighter Market you can't spread a wide
net because it just leaves too much to
chance we have to be like a sniper and
really
identify what sites going to bring my bu
are going to take my business forward
who is actively hiring right now and
what can I do to be to cut through the
noise because everyone else is is honing
in on those and get notice so I just
became more obsessive about my market
maps about my content to them not only
the sell on the candidate and why they
were value but why they were
specifically of value to this company
and what solution they would help solve
for them and that's predominantly from
data from speaking to candidates and
understanding what's going on um
referring back to the conversation
earlier about like typical kind of
problems when you start your career uh
having lower quality candidate
conversations that information only
comes from really probing and
understanding the problem so that you
can provide a solution um so yeah got
got really obsessive about that um and
for me I just picked a a handful of big
ticket sites who these are going to take
my business forward I know they're all
hiring right now I know they all higher
high quality candidates in my market and
pay good
rates I'm going to make them topple um
and I did that was one of your that was
one of your key insights wasn't it it
was mo more more Enterprise clients is
like what you shared to me wasn't it in
terms of when things did get hit you was
maybe over indexed on
compared to having a couple of like big
ticket or big Enterprise clients which
I'm assuming I feel like you um I'm just
assuming here you can tell me otherwise
but I'm assuming these Enterprise
clients can be a bit more trickier to
get into but once you're in them then
there are opportunities but it can like
you said the the good thing is you can
open up doors more quickly Enterprise
clients I'm assuming it takes a bit more
work absolutely it's hell of a lot more
work and there's a lot more room for
error we've been near nearly there with
tons of Enterprise clients where you've
got multiple hiring managers vouching
for you to get you added as a vendor but
it still falls through you get blocked
by HR or the vendor management company
aren't permitting them to add new
vendors right now like there's there's
so many things but you've just got to
find your angle and work it so it is
more problem solving but when you
fundamentally
understand their problems and if you can
leverage your existing relationships as
much as possible to to get them Ino that
that makes it a much easier process two
of the more Enterprise clients that I've
placed with in the the last year have
come off the back of an individual who
they already knew had worked with
previously who I had placed and I'm
taking them to them because I know they
know them but they've not worked at that
Company the company they're at now
before it's like look if you want this
person we've got to find a way to get me
added as a vendor um
um I had the credibility fortunately
with the candidate to do that because
I've placed him multiple times before um
but but that really helped but you've
got to find a way be it through an
existing candidate be it through you
find out who the past through vendors
are and proactively chase them or you
find out who their Consulting partners
are and proactively chase them it
there's a lot more kind of work that
goes into making it happen but there's
always a way go and find it so it sounds
sounds like what makes you feel like
you're building your book now on more um
on stronger
foundations is it sounds like you're
being even more intentional about the
company the sites that you're working
with like even more intentional it
sounds like and then what you've also
really doubled down on is you've always
marketed your contractors and and really
committed to that and and doing that
well but you've really committed to
doing that even better
um and really honed in on if I'm
presenting this person am I presenting
it to the the right person and am I
presenting it to them in a way which
will make them feel like yeah this
person can potentially solve a problem
for me so it seems like you've really
double down on is is that am I
understanding that right yeah absolutely
and just kind of making yourself part of
their Network without them even
realizing and this again boils back to
Market mapping boils back to
understanding the C that you're trying
to Target when I start a BD call and I
can go and say hey look we swim in the
same Circle we're in the same circles I
placed X person X person X person X
person who I know you managed at ex
company instantly there is some
credibility there it's like okay if they
all trust him I can trust so what you're
saying is yeah so what what I take from
that
is how can you get one person away as in
like do you know what I mean yeah so
like if I it's like how can I get one
person away from that person I know
could potentially like be could be like
the person that could keep moving me in
the right direction with his client yeah
yeah or yeah like you said but getting
their Network without knowing it is like
just being one person away you know a
person that knows them but you haven't
had to speak to them yet yeah that's and
it makes it so much easier when you do
know that person and I've been fortunate
with some of these where I can say hey I
know you had a great experience with all
of these guys check out my LinkedIn
recommendations all three of them have
referred me um I place them all in
different projects and then they're like
oh Ellie actually knows all of
these guys and can provide a good
service because his network is in
aligned with the type of people that we
want to we want to
hire so what what I wanted to ask you is
I think what again I always sort of take
this when I speak to people that do
contract recruitment is you've really
got to be smart with the information
that you that you get and you have to
take action on the information that we
get so I guess the the question I want
to ask you is you know so much has been
built on like you just mentioning there
so much has been built on like using the
information that you have to to your
advantage to to move your business
forward like what is it that you found
people struggle with to do that
effectively like like why do you think
people struggle with that sometimes cuz
I'm sure I can tell you Elliot Get leads
and to un blo in the face or I can say
like you know utilize the information
that you get into on blue in the face
but some people don't what why is that
do you
think I think there's a there's there's
two potential kind of challenges both
slightly different one on the quality of
the lead and the depth of understanding
of that lead it's like if you know that
they have a problem great why is that a
problem what what is the potential
solution have they looked into those
Solutions is that something they're
already doing and then the second side
of it is how are you selling that
solution I think a common kind of and
this is probably more phone based and
it's fundamentals of sales when I talk
about solution selling and kind of
providing solutions to your clients
everybody thinks you hear I need a react
engineer you say great I've got a react
engineer that's not solution selling
like we've got to identify a pain Point
like a thread pull up that pain point
until there's no thread left and you
fully understand the problem because
what that does for the manager is it
says actually I know I need a I know I
need a react engineer because my project
why because my project is running behind
schedule easily enough a lot of
recruiters would sell in a candidate at
that point I would always ad go
deeper course what happens if the
project doesn't get delivered on time
what's the knock on effect of that why
is the project running behind What
specifically about your existing
team are they missing or or what skill
set do they have that's not allowing
them to do that and before the end of
the call they've taught you about what
impact this is having on them and their
job they're talking through the pain so
then it's like I'm not just providing
you an engineer because you said you
need an engineer I'm providing you an
engineer with the specific skill set
that is the skills Gap or that is the
problem and you've taken five minutes to
explain to me what implications it has
on your dayto day what the knock on
effect of that will be for the business
and what the opportunity cost is by not
hitting these X goals so make them feel
the pain and talk through that before
you provide a solution so that you know
the solution I'm providing is actually
accurate and the right fit for this
problem does that make sense yeah yeah I
love it like the soundbite that I love
using on this
is like you know High performing
recruiters Chase problems not vacancies
yeah and that's what you're talking
about here and and the thing that I get
from this ell I don't know how you've
helped your
team like get better at that but I feel
like what you're talking about is is
commercial skills is is commercial
Acumen because like you said I could my
ears could be you know uh ringing when I
hear you say I need a react engineer but
actually you're saying hang on a minute
like before you start jumping down their
front and going I've got those react
Engineers like you know I can send them
over to you which a lot of people would
you know a more experienced recruiter or
someone that's really honed their craft
is going to go okay well tell me why you
need that person like you just said and
and actually go the extra step and what
you're uncovering there are actual yeah
I feel like they're commercial skills
and the understanding of how project
work and you know uh understanding that
this person has to probably report to
someone and if they are running behind
what are the knock and effects like how
are you helping people develop that cuz
that's not I wouldn't say that's like
recruitment skills right that's like
commercial skills and we have to educate
people on you know we're actually
solving problems here guys we're not
just placing react
Engineers yeah I think a lot of that's
active listening right um and the more
people can listen into
calls that are executed well the better
they're going to pick those cues up but
also like the more support they have on
calls and you can chip in and
say ask more about that and a lot of the
time it's really simple it's just
why like why is so
often the like there's a uh a rule about
the three Y is like if you ask three
times you actually get the answer to the
first question um and and that's so
often the case is you need somebody to
spell that that out for you but um I
personally
find supporting people on their calls
trying to let them take the lead
themselves but chip in with little bits
of ask why guide them down the right
path rather than and let them ask those
questions themselves and then review at
the end cool what do we get from this
what do we find out what's the problem
what could be the best solution um
versus the old style of telling them
exactly what to say just push them down
the right path um but also have people
listening on your calls if I know I'm
taking a a spec from a client or I'm on
a call with someone that could turn into
that great listening I'm on Zoom jump in
Stick behind the screen hear how hear
how this goes and the questions that I
ask and the direction that I go to just
try and understand what what the
fundamental need is where the problem is
and what solution they need not the
solution they think they need because
it's so often what they think they need
is not what they need love that so as as
we look ahead then be interested to sort
of get your perspective on this as you
look ahead like you said uh you want to
do even better than than you did in the
past talk to us about how you visualize
the sort of Ideal client spread and how
that's going to look cuz it sounds like
that's all also part of your strategy to
there's only so much you can control
right but talk to us a bit about how
you're now strategically thinking if I'm
going to get to 40K weekly GP how do you
visualize that from a client spread
perspective how many Runners do you
think that will be just talk to a bit
about that because I think that will
also get people thinking um because I'm
sure you thought about that that could
because you're going to do that in an
intentional way which it sounds like you
have been that hopefully will mean you
don't find yourself at that 3K Mark
again I mean hopefully you don't but you
know there's only so much you can
control but if I do I I I now know how
to action it and I'll bounce back
quicker and stress less um I'm confident
I won't with the foundations that I'm
setting so for me there's there's a
couple of elements to it this is about
in contract recruitment business
development is King we have to
constantly focus on BD but also be
mindful of the market as I said titter
Market I need to be sniper focused on
where my business is going coming from
as things begin to open
up for me I've got to keep that sniper
focus on what clients are going to give
me the most business over time hire the
best people but also what clients am I
going to provide the best value to I
know where my network is and the people
that best Sue it so I
know the the select few clients that are
going to value my service most um so
they have to be for front all the time
but then it's all about spinning plates
like I've got to still be get a hot lead
I chase it send good content value my
service be very conscious of the quality
of everything I send out feature
Advantage benefit every candidate that
that I work out um both chasing leads
beating into my target sites and mapping
out my candidate Network through those
Target sites identifying cool I
predominantly focused on e-commerce so I
know all the best e-commerce hirers I've
knocked down a lot of those barriers now
maybe I need to Pivot and establish uh
another Market Focus because we've got a
foothold in there if the market turns
for Ecom that's going to be detrimental
to our progress um but equally if you
provide a good service a lot of these
clients don't just disappear so I'm
starting to see now the is that I placed
with two years ago start to come back to
me say hey Elliot we need this person
great I'll still place my ones and twos
with you
because in in different market
conditions they may be the ones that are
more stable and they may be the ones
that kind of uh spread my risk so it's
about ensuring that I'm delivering
across the board but my focus is also on
who's going to who who are kind of bell
steady and uh G to perform well in
turbulent markets and have the volume
and the resources to keep new keep
contracts on board because they're
working on essential projects um but
also just focusing consistently on BD
because if every month you're pulling
new jobs and placing new jobs you can do
that in any market then you don't need
to worry because your focus is then just
can I place more than finish um
obviously with an eye on playing good
defense monitor my contractors make sure
they're happy things are going well kind
of uh be in to the ground to solve any
issues as and when they arise
um whilst being cognizant of BD and
getting your kind of
um uh existing client BD done on those
calls so I've placed with X Enterprise
company there's so much opportunity
there I need to make sure every
contractor I speak to of mine I'm
checking out hey what other what other
new projects are going on have there
been any highers on your team who else
do you know within the business so be is
not just on my target clients it's also
on my existing clients it's also with
every candidate that I speak to and
every kind of hot lead that I gather um
just trying to have that BD head on all
the time and if you pulling enough your
foundations are are going to be solid
because you're you're constantly doing
new
business so then Ju Just to round this
out I mean you might not I don't know
might not work like this I don't know
but I'm just curious
like what do you think your like what do
you think your business will have to
look like to top the 35 or have you not
really thought about that in terms of
like how many Runners do you think that
you'll need and then how have you
thought about what percentage ideally
would you love to land I know it doesn't
work perfectly like this but you know in
an ideal world would you want it to end
up being like 30 40% with Enterprise you
know big companies and then you know 56%
of your book is made up of sites that
are more smmes like how do you just
think about that now with what you've
been through yeah so for five months ago
I sat down and I reviewed every clim
that I work with every active run out I
had this was kind of on my way back up
so was probably 10 to 12K I was like
cool road back to
35k like I need to make sure because
2023 has been a rough year in terms of
annual Billings uh most of my obsession
is around weekly GP and where I'm at but
I'm also for the year it's like if I'm
not billing over a mill in the year
that's a bad year for me that's where I
need to kind of hold myself accountable
um and reviewed what clients I've got in
with now where the numbers need to be
and where I can spread it so I think on
that it worked out about 50% spread
across a number of businesses some of
them were more Enterprise but I've only
tapped into certain teams uh and then I
set myself a plan based on existing
clients how many contractors I'd need to
get for what weekly GP within each
client there and then how many newent
Enterprise clients I need to bring on in
what time periods I worked out if I
focus on on boarding a new Enterprise
client each quarter um over time that
will give me enough enough new business
to to not have to stress but also of my
existing book and existing clients who
can I expand more into and who are
growing um so taking the market and the
current kind of circumstances into
account what do I see as realistic
so each week I can review cool I've said
I want to have X amount of Runners at
this site right now I only have I've
said I want to have five by the end of
the year right now I only have three
from uh I need to be more hot on my
contracts and monitoring calls with
those two and candidate monitor uh
client monitoring calls checking in
seeing how they're performing asking for
internal referrals because that's where
I know there is opportunity so I did a
yeah bit of research on my existing
clients and new and established if I can
get a good split and start to grow each
one internally that's all it takes to
get to to where I need to be and
trajectory wise I'm very confident that
another kind of three to six months and
I I'll I'll be there um providing a few
things line up but we're certainly
moving in the right direction and the
new business is landing at the same rate
as existing and that's where you know
you've got a happy medium yeah I love
that and I think you know if you're
listening right now and you haven't done
an exercise like this or you haven't
made time to do an exercise like this
going into next year is it's the perfect
time to do it cuz you know I'm sure it
can it can feel like definitely for me
when I look at a yearly Target or where
you want to get to it can feel really
overwhelming but then when you just said
like you when you just then reverse
engineer and boil it down to oh so you
know these five sites right now I've got
two contractors in each if I just get
them up to to four each then I'm going
to be where I need to be so you know if
you're listening to this right now and
you haven't done an exercise like Elliot
has just described there would highly
recommend doing some sort of reflection
and looking ahead going into next year
so you can go into next year with you
know more clarity and less
overwhelm um and like you just said like
it then helps you really understand what
you need to be really intentional about
whether that be every time I'm speaking
to these sites I need to make sure I'm
really on the ball with asking what
other projects are going on what's in
the PIP line etc etc so would highly
recommend that if you haven't done
that love it um Elliot look it's been an
absolute pleasure uh kudos to you my man
love love the mindset um no doubt I'm
sure you're going to get to where you
got to even more um really appreciate
you being super honest sharing
everything on here um big thanks for
coming on the Pod thanks for having me I
really enjoyed it um yeah love the show